Judge overseeing the case
against former President
Donald Trump
is now facing new scrutiny tonight
after political donations
that he made to Democrats came to light.
CNN's Kara Scannell is on the story again
for us.
Kara,
these were very small contributions,
but they do raise
an important question of potential bias.
What are you learning
Yeah, Alex, that's right.
And some allies of the former
president are focusing in on that one
in Judge Juan
Mershon, who's overseeing this trial
to recuse himself from this case.
So what we learn from
federal election records
is that the judge had made $35
in donations from in July of 2020.
Those donations $15
went to the Biden campaign.
$10 went to Progressive Turnout Project,
and $10 went to stop Republicans.
Those are two voter turnout groups.
I spoke with a professor of legal ethics
and he says that
the American Bar Association
and the New York
Code of Conduct
could make
some could suggest
that some of these
donations are forbidden.
But he said it's comes nowhere
close to grounds for recusal.
We asked the court
administrators for comment.
They're declining to comment
on these donations tonight.
Alex And Kara,
the district attorney, Alvin
Bragg, is also
pushing back
quite forcefully on House
Republicans here in D.C.
because of the pressure there
that they're putting him under.
What's he saying
Yeah,
I mean, there is
just been this ongoing back and forth
between the House
GOP, the House
Judiciary Chairman,
Jim Jordan,
and the district attorney, Alvin Bragg.
Now, tonight,
Alvin Bragg has a new statement out.
He has tweeted.
The House
GOP continues to attempt
to undermine
an active investigation
and ongoing New York criminal case
with an unprecedented campaign
of harassment and intimidation.
Repeated efforts to weaken state
and local
law enforcement actions
are an abuse of power
and will not deter us from our duty.
To uphold the law.
Now, this statement coming after Jim
Jordan have subpoenaed
a former prosecutor
from that office, Mark Pomeranz.
Pomeranz resigned last year
after Alvin Bragg
would not authorize him
to move forward to seek an indictment
of the former president
related to the accuracy
of his financial statements.
Jordan now
wanting Pomeranz to come in
for testimony.
He said on April 20th deadline, and
Pomeranz is declining comment tonight.
But we should note that previously
when Jordan asked
for this voluntary interview,
he told them that
the district attorney's office
directed him to not cooperate
with their investigation. Alex.
All right.
Chris Scannell in New York,
thank you so much, Carol,
for all your terrific reporting.
Let's get analysis now
from our legal and political experts
Andrew McCabe, I want to start with you
and the judge's contributions
to President Biden and Democrats.
It is,
as Carol and I
were saying, a minimal amount.
$35, but it's still not a good look
for a judge to have made these
donations, is it?
It's not a great look,
Alex, but let's be honest.
Do we
are we at a place
in American political life
where if you have participated in the
in the political system
at all as a voter
or a supporter of candidates
you're now
excluded from, execute
any sort of judgment or responsibility
over someone from the other party?
That seems absurd.
You know, we have seen
many appeals of Donald
pushed by Donald Trump on many issues
in the last couple of weeks
that have been heard by judges
who he appointed to the bench.
And you didn't hear any cry
for having those folks
recuse themselves
as well as they shouldn't have.
So I really think at the end of the day,
this is much ado about nothing.
Shane, would you.
Do you agree that it's absurd
or do you think the judge
there should be a conversation
about the judge recusing himself
Absolutely not.
I agree with Andrew.
This is absurd.
Some minuscule amount.
I mean, by comparison.
If you look at the ridiculous
luxury trips taken in secret by Justice
Clarence Thomas,
and there is no requirement
of transparency there,
what we see here,
there's a requirement of transparency.
The judge disclosed these contributions
if the House and Congress
want to do something constructive.
Let's make the Supreme Court
disclose all these luxurious secret
gifts and trips that they take. Yeah.
Those trips
and gifts from a Republican mega-donor
in an explosive new report by ProPublica.
Andrew, we only have about a minute left,
but I want to ask you
about what we just heard
Kara talking about attorney
that the attorney general, Alvin Bragg,
sorry, district attorney,
rather, his forceful response
to those House Republicans.
He called their attempts
an unprecedented campaign of harassment
and intimidation.
What do you make of that?
I think he's exactly right.
I mean, let's let's face
it, on the federal level,
the Department of Justice refuses
often
gets requests
from Congress to go up and talk
about ongoing investigations.
They routinely refuse to do so.
This is a case
that is still being prosecuted
We are a long way
before any point at which the
the prosecutors
should be appearing before any sort of
congressional panel
to talk about what they're doing.
I'm not sure that they ever should.
And there's a state federal issue
involved here as well.
So I believe he's on the right ground.
All right.
Well, we'll certainly hear more
I would imagine, from Congressman Jordan
in that back and forth as Shan Wu.
Andrew McCabe,
thank you, as always, for your time
and your insight tonight.